مشاهدينا هذه الصور اذا بثتها قبل قليل
غرفه العمليات المشتركه للفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لدفعه من الصواريخ التي اطلقت
من قطاع غزه باتجاه المدن الاسرائيليه في
ضمن هذه الجوله من المواجهات مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه التي
تستمر في غاراتها على قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
نذكر مشاهدينا ان الصواريخ التي اطلقت من
قطاع غزه كانت بين متوسطه وبعيده المدى
بعضها استطاع الوصول الى جنوبي تل ابيب
اليوم تحديدا قد قتل مستوطن اسرائيلي وجرح
العديد من المستوطنين في سقوط صاروخ في
منطقه روحفو تحديدا وايضا وصلت الصواريخ
الى ريشون هي مناطق تبعد حوالي 50 كيلومتر
من اذا تل ابيب ولكن من اعظم قطاع غزه
ولكن ايضا لا تزال يمكن القول ان مدايات
الصواريخ التي تصل اليها صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كانت تصل الى مدايات ابعد من
ذلك نذكر انها وصلت الى القدس والى داخل
وسط تل ابيب عموما هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه
كانت كثيفه جدا استطاعت تجاوز القبه
الحديديه وايضا ما سمي بمقلاع داوود وهي
انظمه لح المدن الاسرائيليه تدعي اسرائيل
انها ذات فعاليه عاليه وانها تتعامل مع
انواع صواريخ المختلفه متوسطه وقصيره
وطويله المدى ولكن كما لاحظنا فان
الصواريخ صواريخ المقاومه استطاعت تتجاوز
هذه او هاتين المنظومتين واصابه اهداف
داخل المدن الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
اذا سرايا القدس جناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه هي التي نشرت هذه الصور
التي تظهر اطلاق صواريخ اذن من عدد من
الصواريخ دفعه من الصواريخ باتجاه اذا مدن
اسرائيليه من داخل قطاع غزه
تشاهدونها اذا في هذه الصور